لقد قلت إن إيران
ستنتقم من الاغتيال المستهدف للجنرال
قاسم سليماني ، قال الرئيس ترامب إنه
سيكون هناك رد غير متناسب
إذا فعلت ذلك ، فما
رأيك بتهديدات الرئيس ترامب
لم تخيفنا تهديداته ولكن
ما يظهره هو  أن يُظهر
للمجتمع الدولي أنه لا
يحترم القانون الدولي أنه
مستعد لارتكاب جرائم حرب لأن
مهاجمة المواقع الثقافية جريمة حرب
في هذا الرد غير المتناسب هو
جريمة حرب لكنه لا يهتم
بالأمر على ما يبدو  القانون الدولي ولكن هل
جعلنا أكثر أمانًا ، هل يشعر الأمريكيون
بمزيد من الأمان ، فإن الأمريكيين يرحب بهم اليوم
في هذه المنطقة ، هل يشعرون بالترحيب
بحكومتك وقيادتك
والجيش قد تعهدوا باتخاذ إجراءات
ضد مزاعم الولايات المتحدة
بأن الولايات المتحدة انتهكت ثلاثة
مبادئ السيادة العراقية
والاتفاق الذي عقدوه مع العراق
حصلوا على رد من مجلس النواب العراقي
لقد انتهكوا مشاعر
الناس وسوف يتلقون رد فعل من الأشخاص
الذين قتلوا أحد أكثر قادتنا احتراما
وكبار قادتنا
وتحملوا المسؤولية عن
هذا إرهاب دولة وهذا عمل
عدواني ضد إيران وهو
بمثابة  هجوم مسلح ضد إيران
وسنرد ولكننا سنرد
بشكل متناسب وليس غير متناسب
لأننا ملتزمون بالقانون فنحن ملتزمون
بالقانون ولسنا خارجين عن القانون
مثل الرئيس ترامب لذلك تعتقد أنه
يمكنك ضرب أي وقت بشكل جيد نحن
لأنه من الواضح أنك  لا يخفى على أحد
أنك تسيطر على الميليشيات في هذه المنطقة
أن لديك قوات في
صفك في هذه المنطقة في العديد من البلدان.
وجد أشخاص إلى جانبنا في هذه ال
نطقة ، والأهم من ذلك بكثير أن ال
لايات المتحدة تعتقد أن هذه ال
عدات العسكرية الجميلة وف
ًا للرئيس.  ROM أنك أنفقت
تريليوني دولار على هذه
المعدات العسكرية الجميلة ، فإن المعدات العسكرية الجميلة
لا تحكم العمل
الناس يحكمون العالم ، يجب على الولايات
المتحدة أن تستيقظ على حقيقة
أن شعوب هذه المنطقة غاضبة
لأن شعوب هذه المنطقة تريد
خروج الولايات المتحدة
ولا تستطيع الولايات المتحدة البقاء في هذه المنطقة مع
شعوب المنطقة.  عدم الرغبة في ذلك
بعد الآن ، هل يستحق الأمر التحدث
إليه جيدًا لا يحتاج إلى التحدث
إلى الفوضى لإدراك أنه قد تم تغذيته
بمعلومات خاطئة وأنه بحاجة إلى الاستيقاظ
والاعتذار عليه أن يعتذر عليه
أن يغير المسار ولا يمكنه إضافة خطأ
إلى آخر  مخطئًا ، إنه يجعل الأمور
أسوأ بالنسبة لأمريكا ، فهو يدمر
الدستور الأمريكي ، إنه يدمر
العملية السياسية الأمريكية ، فهو يدمر
سيادة القانون في الولايات المتحدة ، لكن
هذا ليس بالنسبة لي لأقول أن هذا
شأن داخلي للولايات المتحدة ،
فقد أثار غضب الولايات المتحدة.  الناس من
منطقتنا قتل الناس في هذه المنطقة
لقد أنفق تريليون دولار قال
إن الولايات المتحدة أهدرت سبعة تريليونات
دولار في منطقتنا وأضاف
تريليون آخر  أصبحت الولايات المتحدة
أكثر أمانًا اليوم بسبب أن
الولايات المتحدة وإدارة ترامب
تقولان أنه
قبل الضربة على الجنرال سليماني
كانت هناك استفزازات من قبل إيران والقوات
التي تسيطر عليها إيران كانت هناك قواعد
تم قصفها بالصواريخ هناك
كمقاول أمريكي كان  قُتل
ثم كانت هناك احتجاجات في
السفارة التي دمرت
خارج السفارة وفرضت
حصارًا جيدًا على القنصلية الإيرانية
في النجف ، هل اتخذنا إجراءات
ضد أي شخص يجب أن تدرك الولايات المتحدة
أن الناس في العراق غاضبون
وهم يتعاملون مع غضبهم بالطبع ،
فهم أكثر غضبًا من الولايات
المتحدة وأي شخص آخر ، لكن
المهم بالنسبة للولايات المتحدة أن
تدركه حتى يدرك نظام ترامب
أن كل شيء في هذه المنطقة
كان يتحسن وفقًا لـ jcpoa ماذا
حدث أن الولايات المتحدة بدأت
حملة ضغط أقصى ترهيب
الشعب الإيراني
مما جعل من الصعب على الإيرانيين القيام بذلك  حتى
الحصول على الطعام والدواء من الخارج ، لذا فقد
بدأت الحرب منذ وقت طويل من
قبل الولايات المتحدة في الوقت الحالي ، فليس
هناك خطر من
أن كل هذا قد ينحدر إلى
شيء أسوأ بكثير ، لا
تقولين إنك إيطالي سيقولون  لقد
كانوا إيطاليين ، أليس هناك خطر
اندلاع حرب شاملة يمكن أن تدمر
أجزاء كبيرة من تاريخك والشرق
الأوسط ، فنحن نجلس في منزلنا
سندافع عن أراضينا ،
وسندافع عن شعبنا الذي تستطيع الولايات المتحدة القيام به
الدفاع عن الولايات المتحدة ولكن الولايات
المتحدة لا تستطيع حتى الادعاء بأنها تدافع
عن الولايات المتحدة على بعد 7000 ميل من
الوطن ، فنحن هنا لن نتحرك لأننا
كنا هنا منذ سبعة آلاف عام
سنستمر في التواجد هنا والولايات
المتحدة قادمة جديدة
[  موسيقى]